QUESTION FROM HIM. DID THE
GIANTS DRAFT DAY TRADE WITH
THE BEAR, SET THEM UP FOR A
TRADE FOR A QUARTERBACK IN
2022, SUCH AS A RUSSELL
WILSON. AND YOU THINK ABOUT
IT, THE GIANTS PICKED UP
CHICAGO'S FIRST ROUNDER NEXT
YEAR. THEY'LL HAVE THEIR OWN
COULD THROW IN 2023. THERE'S
YOUR THREE. AND WHETHER IT'S
RUSSELL WILSON, REMEMBER,
HE WAS LINKED TO THE GIANTS A
COUPLE OF YEARS AGO WHEN THE
RUMOR MILL WAS STARTING TO
CHURN IS RUSSELL WAS TRYING
TO GET THAT BIG NEW CONTRACT,
THE GIANTS DID COME UP IN
THAT CONVERSATION AT THE TIME
OR COULD BE DESHAUN WATSON,
OR IT COULD BE AARON RODGERS,
YOU COULD BE ANYBODY BECAUSE
THIS IS THE UPPER OUT YEAR,
DANIEL JONES, NO MORE EXCUSES.
FOR DANIEL JONES, AFTER THEY
GIVE KENYALA DAY, ALL THAT
MONEY, THEY DRAFT COULD AREAS,
TONY, THEY'VE GOT SE KWANG
BERKELEY, THEY'VE GOT WEAPONS
GALORE OFFENSIVELY,
THEY WANT.
SEE, A JOSH ALLEN TYPE OF A
JUMP FROM DANIEL JONES. AND
IF IT DOESN'T HAPPEN TO RAIN,
I THINK EVERYTHING'S ON THE
TABLE FOR NEXT YEAR,
INCLUDING PACKAGING. FIRST,
ROUND PICKS TO GO GET RUSSELL
WILSON, OR DESHAUN WATSON,
OR AARON RODGERS, OR WHATEVER
OTHER QUARTERBACK. THAT'S OUT
THERE THAT WE THINK IS HAPPY
DECIDES HE WANTS A FRESH
START SOMEWHERE ELSE.
MIKE, I LOVE WHAT SOME OF
THESE TEAMS HAVE DONE,
WASHINGTON, THE GIANTS, THE
BRONCOS, PERHAPS, THE RAIDERS,
THEY HAVE CAR. SO THEIR
SITUATION IS A LITTLE BIT
DIFFERENT, BUT SOME OF THESE
TEAMS WHO WE KNOW HAVE AN
OBVIOUS NEED FOR A
QUARTERBACK AND THEY SAT BACK
AND THEY PREACH PATIENT
PATIENTS. YOU LOOK AT RON
RIVERA PREACH PATIENTS ABOUT
FINDING THAT QUARTERBACK AND
THE SOME OF THESE TEAMS ARE
GOING TO END UP WITH A
DESHAUN WATSON, A RUSSELL
ROGERS AND THEY'RE GOING TO
BE BETTER FOR IT AND THEY'RE
GOING TO BE BETTER THAN SOME
OF THESE QUARTERBACKS WHO
WERE DRAFTED. I REALIZED
THESE GUYS ARE YOUNGER, BUT
WE SEE IT EVERY YEAR. MIKE,
THESE QUARTERBACKS COME INTO
THE DRAFT, AND THEY DON'T MIC
MAKE IT, AND THAT'S WHERE
DANIEL JONES IS RIGHT. NOW,
WE TALK ABOUT THE INJURIES,
ALL WE WANT. JOE JUDGE WENT
ON HIS INJURIES WERE SERIOUS.
90% OF THE PLAYERS IN THE
LEAGUE WOULD HAVE HAD TO SIT
OUT FROM THESE INJURIES. HE
DIDN'T HAVE SE KWANG BERKELEY.
HE DIDN'T HAVE THIS. HE
DIDN'T HAVE THAT. IT'S ALL
DONE. NOW. GO GET IT. DONE
THIS YEAR.
ARE YOU WILL BE REPLACED NEXT
YEAR? AND I THINK THE GIANTS
WILL BE SITTING PRETTY WHEN
IT COMES TO FINDING A
QUARTERBACK NEXT YEAR. IF HE
DOESN'T GET IT DONE THIS YEAR
AND YOU KNOW WHAT? SOMETHING
OCCURRED TO ME?
WE HAD CARSON WENTZ WANT OUT
OF PHILADELPHIA. HE GOT OUT
OF PHILADELPHIA, WE HAD
RUSSELL WILSON, ONE OUT OF
SEATTLE THAT HAS DISSIPATED
FOR NOW. DESHAUN WATSON,
WANTING OUT OF HOUSTON.
DISSIPATED FOR DIFFERENT
REASONS, AARON RODGERS
WANTING OUT OF GREEN BAY.
FOUR OUT OF THIRTY TWO
STARTING QUARTERBACKS WHO'S
THE NEXT WAVE OF YOUNG
QUARTERBACK THAT WANTS HOW IT
MATTHEW STAFFORD GOING AROUND,
OF ESTABLISHED QUARTERBACK.
IT WANTS OUT. I THINK IT'S
FOOLISH TO NOT AT LEAST BE
WONDERING. I'M NOT GOING TO
NAME NAMES HERE. WE ALL HAVE
ACCESS TO THE STANDINGS. YOU
CAN LOOK AT THE 32 TEAMS. YOU
CAN CONSIDER THE QUARTERBACK
SITUATIONS. AND I THINK THE
BROADER MESSAGE HERE IS THAT
ALL THESE OTHER QUARTERBACKS
ARE WATCHING THIS AND YOU GET
UNHAPPY WITH YOUR SITUATION
SHIREEN
YOU START RATTLING, THE CAGE
YOU WANT OUT. YOU WANT OUT
ONE OUT AND YOU DO IT
PRIVATELY, YOU DO IT PUBLICLY.
YOU DO A LITTLE BIT OF BOTH,
BUT AS MORE AND MORE GUYS ARE
DOING IT MORE AND MORE GUYS
WHO AREN'T HAPPY WITH THEIR
TEAMS, ARE GOING TO FEEL
EMBOLDENED TO DO IT AND A LOT
OF ITS GOING TO DEPEND UPON
HOW GOOD THE TEAM IS AROUND
AND HOW MUCH THEY'RE
LISTENING TO HIM. COUPLE OF
FACTORS AND AND THIRD HOW
MUCH YOU GET PAID, HOW MUCH
YOU PAID? HOW MUCH DO YOU
LISTEN TO HIM AND HOW GOOD
THE TALENT IS AROUND HIM?
GUYS CAN SAY I'D RATHER GO
SOMEWHERE ELSE. HERE'S A
QUESTION.
THAT CAME IN VIA EMAIL FROM
MATTHEW IN ENGLAND. I WANT
TRY ON THIS ONE BECAUSE I
LIKE THIS. NOT THAT I
SOMETHING THAT OTHER PLAYERS
HAVE DONE IN OTHER CITIES AND
OTHER SETTINGS, COULD AARON
RODGERS SHOW UP AND CLAIM AN
INJURY SO THAT HE GETS PAID
AND STILL KEEPS LEVERAGE BY
REFUSING TO PLAY. THIS IS
HOLDING IN, YOU CAN HOLD OUT
OR YOU CAN HOLD IN. AND THERE
BEEN GUYS OVER THE YEARS, WHO
SHOW UP AND
WILL EITHER NOT PLAY THROUGH
AN INJURY THAT THEY OTHERWISE
WOULD PLAY THROUGH IF THEY
WERE HAPPY OR JUST FLAT-OUT.
SORRY
GUYS HAVE DONE THAT GUYS HAVE
DONE THAT. I DON'T THINK
AARON RODGERS. HEY LUANNE.
SEE I THINK IF HE'S THERE
HE'S GOING TO PLAY BUT IT IS
A WEAPON THAT'S AVAILABLE TO
PLAYERS AND IT'S VERY HARD
FOR TEAMS TO DEAL WITH IT
BECAUSE THEN YOU HAVE TO BE
THE ONE TO BE THE BAD GUY WHO
SUGGESTS THE GUY WHO'S
INJURED, WHO CLAIMS HE'S
YEAH. WELL GO BACK TO JAIL
AND RAMSEY RAMSAY, I CAN'T
REMEMBER HOW MANY INJURIES HE
WENT THROUGH BEFORE. HE
FINALLY GOT HIS TRADE TO THE
RAMS, RIGHT? MIKE BUT HE GOT
HIS TRADE TO THE RAMS IT
HAPPENED AND SO GUYS
CERTAINLY CAN DO THAT NOT A
PROPONENT OF IT BUT THEY HAVE
DONE IT, THEY WILL DO IT AND
IT'S A WAY FOR THEM TO GET
THEIR WAY AND IT'S WORKED,
I'M SURPRISED MORE GUYS
HAVEN'T TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF
AND AGAIN, I'M NOT SAYING
THAT I WOULD AGREE WITH THIS
APPROACH, BUT YOU GOT
MILLIONS OF DOLLARS AT STAKE
HERE, I'M SURPRISED MORE GUYS
HAVEN'T TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF.
SURPRISED MORE GUYS HAVEN'T
TAKEN ADVANTAGE OF, YOU KNOW,
I BUSY TODAY. I THINK I MAY
HAVE GOTTEN A CONCUSSION IN
THE GAME THE OTHER DAY. WELL
HOW ARE YOU DOING TODAY?
HEADACHES MEAN, HOW DO YOU,
HOW DO YOU DISPROVE THAT?
AND I THINK GUYS USE SOFT
TISSUE INJURIES TO THAT
EFFECT. YOU KNOW, THE
HAMSTRING IS USUALLY, ONE OF
THE THINGS THAT CAN LINGER
AND LINGER AND LINGER.
SO WE'RE ON THE SAME
PAGE, WE DON'T CONDONE IT,
BUT BE NAIVE TO THINK IT
NEVER HAPPENS. I'D BE STUNNED.
IF IT HAPPENS WITH AARON
RODGERS. I DON'T THINK HE
WOULD DO SOMETHING LIKE THAT.
SHIREEN, NO, I ABSOLUTELY. I
THINK AARON RODGERS SHOWS UP
AND HE'S GOING TO BE ALL IN
IF HE SHOWS UP. THE QUESTION
IS, IS HE GOING TO SHOW UP
MIKE? AND I THINK THE ANSWER
RIGHT NOW, AS WE SIT HERE
TODAY IS PROBABLY NO, YEAH,
I AGREE WITH YOU IF HE'S
THERE, HE'S ALL IN. THE
AND WE'LL FIND OUT SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER. YOU'LL